[Music]
and welcome everybody to Long crime
daily I'm Jesse Weber the Alec Murdock
murder trial came to a screeching halt
on Wednesday thanks to a bomb threat
called into the courthouse
authorities evacuated the Colleton
County Courthouse just before 1 pm on
Wednesday an official told The State
newspaper that the threat was called in
specifically against judge Clifton
Newman the caller apparently said a bomb
was inside the judge's Chambers which
are on the second floor of the
courthouse the state's 38 38th witness
was about to take the stand when judge
Newman brought everything to a halt and
asked for the jury to just be dismissed
he then told everyone in the courtroom
that they had to leave Murdoch and the
jury were also taken away from the
courthouse and deputies set up a
perimeter around the block more than two
hours later though Court resumed with
that 38th witness finally able to be
questioned officials haven't said
whether that threat was ever
substantiated
now before the courtroom was evacuated
part of the day's testimony focused on
gunshot primer residue you see the
defense cross-examined a forensic
examiner with the South Carolina law
enforcement Division and she testified
that 38 particles were identified on the
inside of a blue rain jacket prosecutors
have suggested that those particles
could have gotten there if the raincoat
was wrapped around a gun possibly to
hide it investigators also found
particles on the shirt that Alec Murdock
was wearing on the night of the murders
as well as his shorts and one particle
on his hands however the defense pointed
out that gunshot primer residue can be
easily transferred from one surface to
another and can stay on a surface for a
very long periods of time unless someone
actually removed removed it now it's
been well established throughout the
trial that the murdochs often use guns
for hunting and had various guns on the
property a murder weapon though has
never been recovered in this case I want
to bring in my special a team Brian
buckmeyer Terry Austin Brown I'll start
with you what exactly is gunshot res to
do and what are they testing for all
right so Jesse a person pulls the
trigger over a gun and that causes the
firing to strike the primer and that's
located at the base of the cartridge now
the primer strikes and turns you got
sparks and then it's a chemical reaction
right ignites the gunpowder resulting in
explosion shoots that bullet outside of
the gun and so what they're testing for
is the gas that comes out of the gun
along with a bullet there's typically
unburnt gunpowder tiny bits of metal and
signature chemicals from the primer
mixing usually with lead and and other
types of substances like barium sorry
and that fused together with the heat
and of the gun firing it settles on a
person's clothing and other nearby
surfaces so what they're really testing
is the quantity and the amount of these
distinct chemicals that indicates that a
person either one recently fired a gun
was either two uh in the very close
proximity to a gun when it was fired or
three came into direct physical contact
with a person who did the firing this is
less common because if it's a direct
contact type of situation there are
fewer particles but that's actually what
the defense is arguing that there may be
a direct contact argument rather than
the actual firing well Terry The Gunshot
residue is something that the
prosecution really honed in on in the
opening statement I mentioned all the
places that where it was located you
think that's enough to convict Alec
Murdoch well it's a good start it was
also located on the Buckle of that seat
belt in that Suburban so it's a number
of locations and if you couple all of
the circumstantial evidence and it is
circumstantial but that's just as good
as direct evidence if you couple that
with the fact Paul's video with cash and
Bubba having the voice of Alex in the
background I think is pivotal then you
also have his nurse for his mom saying
that he suggested that she say it was 30
to 40 minutes instead of 15 to 20. so I
think if you put all of this
circumstantial evidence together the
prosecution has a solid case or solid
enough I think if the jury accepts that
it was the rain jacket he was holding
and he crumpled it up a week after the
murders and has The Gunshot residue that
is going to be devastating for the
defense that's my take but I'll tell you
what a long crime is covering this trial
for you gavel to gavel you can go to
longcrime.com to see the latest articles
live streams and of course expert
insight
[Music]
we're following a celebrity murder trial
out of Broward County Florida that we
want to talk about three men are facing
life in prison for the 2018 shooting
death of rap Rising rap artist Jase
onfroy known by his stage name XXX
tentacion the artist was just 20 years
old when he was shot and killed at a
motorcycle dealership he was allegedly
ambushed by two masked men while driving
out of the parking lot you see the two
men are also accused of stealing on
Freud's designer Satchel which had fifty
thousand dollars cash inside as well as
the rapper's personal belongings
prosecutors say defendants Michael
Boatwright and Trayvon Newsom are
responsible for shooting on Freud while
Dietrich Williams drove the getaway car
a fourth co-defendant Robert Allen
pleaded guilty to second-degree murder
and robbery with a firearm and as part
of as part of his plea deal he is
required to testify against his
co-defendants and you know what he did
just that on Wednesday here's what he
had to say
what bag
s
okay do you remember what kind of bag it
was yes tell us
what is uh Trayvon doesn't do after he
grabs the bag as he's grabbing his bag
shops on fire who shoots the shots that
are fired
and who does he shoot
simple levels what is Michael Bolt
writing next
what does Trayvon Newsom do
you kind of like Steps steps and fall
like a little bit
what does Dietrich Williams do now are
all four of you back in the Dodge
Journey yes what does Dietrich Williams
do
you dry as well
Terry in addition to that devastating
testimony the prosecution has evidence
of cell phones surveillance footage it
seems like a pretty straightforward
prosecution I have to ask you though do
you think law enforcement should have
investigated other theories or not
absolutely not that would have been a
waste of time this is clear-cut there's
video and now you have one of the
defendants talking about what exactly
happened and testifying against the
other three defendants I think just
because XXX mentioned Drake on an
interview and he later withdrew that
comment doesn't mean that they should be
pursuing these theories they only have a
certain amount of time and resources to
go after the real suspects here and they
did just that they have witnesses who
saw them come into that motorcycle they
you know the store there and they have
they have the video so I definitely
don't think they should have been
pursuing these these ludicrous theories
Brian though robbery with a mask what's
likely to come from the defense arguing
it's not their client yeah so the
prosecution already laid it out Jesse
that they want the jury to look at the
person's gate their height the way they
moved but getting told people to agree
on the way that someone walks is
difficult and that's an Avenue for which
the defense can create reasonable doubt
it's difficult to say to this person you
don't know you've never seen before they
walk a certain way and that they're
supposed to identify them based on that
but the prosecution can lean on these
other witnesses that give them other
forms of evidence to identify the
defendants in this case but I do think
there is some argument there whether or
not it's Reasonable Doubt or not is up
for the jury to decide but there's
something for the defense to kind of
sink their teeth into there there
reasonable Reasonable Doubt this looks
pretty bad for all of them